hi in this video I will explain
regression analysis to you in a simple
way first you will learn what a
regression is and what it is used for
and then we will look at the difference
between simple linear regression
multiple linear regression and logistic
regression at the end we will calculate
a real world example we will analyze the
housing market and I will show you how
you can interpret the results with the
help of AI so what does regression
analysis do a regression analysis allows
you to infer or predict one variable
based on one or more other variables
let's say you want to find out what
influences a person's salary for example
you could take the highest level of
Education the weekly working hours and
the age of a person you could now
investigate whether these three
variables have an influence on a
person's salary if they do then you can
predict the person's salary using the
highest level of Education the weekly
working hours and the person's age the
variable you want to infer the one you
want to predict is called the dependent
variable or criteria the variables you
use for prediction are called
independent variables or predictors
regression analysis can now be used to
achieve two goals you can measure the
influence of what one or more variables
on another variable or you can predict
one variable based on other variables to
give you a feeling for this let's go
through some examples let's start by
measuring the influence of one or more
variables on another as part of our
research you may be interested in what
influences children's ability to
concentrate you're interested in whether
you can prove that there are parameters
that POS positively or negatively
influence children's ability to
concentrate but you're not interested in
predicting children's ability to
concentrate or you could investigate
whether the educational level of the
parents and the place of residence have
an influence on the future educational
level of children the first area is
there for very research-based and has
many applications in the social and
economic Sciences the second area using
regression to make predictions is more
application oriented to make the best
use of Hospital capacity you may be
interested in how long a patient will
stay in hospital so based on the
characteristic of the prospective
patient such as age reason for admission
and pre-existing conditions you want to
know how long that person is likely to
stay in hospital this prediction can
then be used to optimize bad planning
one more example if you run an online
shop you're very interested in which
product a person is most likely to buy
you want to suggest this product to the
visitor in order to increase the sales
of the online shop this is where
regression comes in now there are
different types of regression analysis
but they are not difficult to understand
let's get started in regression analysis
a distinction is made between simple
linear multiple linear and logistic
regression simple linear regression uses
only one independent variable to infer
the dependent variable in the example
where we want to predict the salary of a
person we use only one variable either
whether one has studied or not the
weekly working hours or the age of a
person multiple linear regression uses
several independent variables to in fear
the dependent variable so you use the
highest education level the weekly
working hours and the age of a person in
order to predict its salary therefore
the difference between a simple linear
regression and a miltiple regression is
that once only one independent variable
is used and the other one uses several
both have in common that the dependent
variable is metric for example a
person's salary height shoe size or
electricity consumption in contrast
logistic regression is used when you
have a categorical dependent variable
for example when you want to inere
whether a person is at risk of burnout
or not whenever you have yes no answers
you use logistic regression does a
person buy a product yes or no is a
person healthy or sick does a person
vote for a certain party or not and so
on and so forth so in summary in linear
regression the dependent variable is
metric in logistic regression it is
categorical the scale level of the
dependent variable can be metric ordinal
or nominal in all three cases I.E in the
simple linear in the multiple linear and
in the logistic regression the dependent
variable metric in the linear case and
nominal or ordinal in the case of
logistic regression it is important to
note that in the case of nominal or
ordinal independent variables the
variables can classically have only two
characteristics such as gender with male
and female if your variables have more
than two characteristics you need to
create so-called dami variables I have a
separate video on the topic of dami
variables so so there is the simple
linear regression a question could be
does the weekly working time have an
impact on the hourly wage of employees
in this case we only have one
independent variable if we look at the
multiple linear regression we could have
the question do the weekly working time
and the age of employees have an
influence on the hourly wage here we
have at least two independent variables
in this case weekly working time and age
and the last case logistic regression do
the weekly working time and the age of
employees have an influence on the
probability that they are at risk of
burnout finally let's look at the real
world example and analyze the housing
market data will then automatically
interpret the results for you to do this
go to data.net and load the example data
set the link is in the video description
you can also copy your own data into
this table then click on regression
afterwards you can select the dependent
variable and one or more independent
variables depending on the scale level
of your dependent variable either a
lineal or a logistic regression will be
calculated in our example the dependent
variable is price per square meters as
dependent variables we can select the
size of the house the number number of
rooms the age of the house in years and
the distance from the city center since
we have a metric dependent variable a
linear regression is automatically
calculated and here we see the results
for each table data tab gives you an
automatically generated
interpretation further you can also
click on summary inverts above I
mentioned earlier that it is important
to check the assumptions before
calculating a regression so check out my
deep dive where I will show you what the
assumptions of the linear regression are
and how to test them thanks for watching
and I hope you enjoyed the
video